- [Joma] Thanks to IBM for
sponsoring a part of this video.
- [Dio] My name is Dio
and I was on track for a return offer,
until one day he showed up.
(ominous music)
A newly recruited intern
appeared out of nowhere,
a shadow from my past.
(ominous music continues)
His name was Jojoma.
- [Jojoma] You must be Dio.
- Yeah, and you are?
- [Jojoma] You know who I am.
- What?
- Do you really think I'd forget
what you've taken from me, brother?
♪ Let's ♪
- What are you talking about?
- 20 years ago,
a man in crippling debt
sold his firstborn child
to clear his name,
to rebuild his life.
He even got a new child,
gave him all the love in the world.
- I had nothing to do with any of this.
- That man was your father, our father.
You stole my life,
and I'm here to take it all back,
starting with a Kodocharenji.
(metal screeches)
♪ I could change ♪
(ominous music)
- Let's talk about IBM.
IBM believes what businesses
need most to drive progress
in this next era is creativity.
Yes, you heard that correctly, creativity.
I'm not talking about creativity
in a traditional sense,
like musicians and artists.
I'm talking about the developers,
the data scientists, the visionaries,
who are creatively applying technology
in business to drive change.
IBM calls them New Creators.
I love this because I've
always believed that technology
is a tool that we should leverage
to create real values
in our everyday lives,
just like these New Creators.
New Creators think outside the box.
They are wired to do things differently,
as long as it makes a positive impact.
One of the New Creators
I resonate with is Nick.
He's a Senior Data and AI
Technical Specialist at IBM.
Nick is passionate about using technology,
machine learning and data science
to solve new and novel problems
that make a difference.
One example of this is when
he used Computer Vision
to decode and translate sign language
in real-time to break
down language barriers
and create more accessibility online.
- The main goal is to make the world
just that little bit better.
If I can do that,
then I think my time on this planet
will have been well served.
Producing technologies
and using technologies
for the greater good of humanity,
I think that's my core goal here.
- Just like Nick, I
believe in doing things
that add intrinsic value.
So to learn more about New Creators,
you can check out IBM on
their YouTube channel,
or you could click the link
in the description down below.
So again, thank you so much IBM
for sponsoring this portion of my video.
- Welcome back, everyone.
Today's Kodocharenji, we
have Jojoma versus Dio.
(intense music)
- [Masked Man] At this company,
there is one way for interns
to settle their differences.
A Kodocharenji is a coding battle
where two interns receive
the same coding challenge.
They will be judged on their-
- Speed, efficiency and correctness.
The winner will receive a return offer,
but the loser will be kicked out
of this company immediately.
Today's challenge: hack
this smart contract.
- [Dio] Blockchain? Oh, no.
- You have 60 minutes
to submit your exploit.
Begin coding.
(intense music)
- [Masked Man] Dio's
fundamentals are strong.
This internship has taught
him all the essential skills
required to becoming an elite engineer.
(intense music continues)
Jojoma might be
underestimating his opponent.
(intense music continues)
(keys clacking)
(sparks crackling)
(intense music continues)
(Jojoma exhales)
(Masked Man gasps)
Nani?
I've never seen someone so young
use such an advanced move.
Is he actually reading documentation?
(intense music continues)
(no audio)
(scroll wheel winding)
(sparks crackling)
(intense music)
- 15 minutes have passed.
Remember, even if you
found the vulnerability,
you still have to build out your exploit.
- [Dio] Oh, no, this is not going well.
Come on, come on.
I really need you right now.
(Dio groans)
(intense music)
Yes, the Debugger's Eye allows me
to quickly see all the possible code paths
without needing to
compile or run the code.
This allows me spot bugs
before they even happen.
(intense music continues)
- [Masked Man] Dio comes from a long line
of software developers,
tracing back to the first developers
during the Age of Enlightenment,
who all had the Debugger's Eye.
This eye gets activated
in times of stress.
Some say it's an evolutionary adaptation
for developers to meet their deadlines
when working with
unreasonable product managers.
Wait, but these two are brothers.
That means...
(intense music)
Incredible, he has two of them.
Can it be?
The Descendant of Codekage himself?
- 15 minutes left.
Code submission to the judges is now open.
(notification chimes)
(intense music)
(metal screeches)
(intense music continues)
(keys clack)
Amazing, Jojoma pulls out another keyboard
to double his coding speed!
I've never seen anything like this before.
(Masked Man gasps)
- [Masked Man] Impossible,
this dual yielding technique.
That can only mean he was trained
in the Hidden Village of Goruden Suteito,
also known as the San Francisco Bay Area.
(intense music continues)
(keys clacking)
- Once you've completed your challenge,
you will have to submit
your code to the judges.
(intense music continues)
(keys clacking)
(notification chimes)
(intense music continues)
(keys clacking)
(notification chimes)
(intense music continues)
(alarm rings)
Challenge over!
We'll now proceed to the
grading phase of this challenge.
- [Masked Man] Something
doesn't feel right.
- You know, taking your job offer
is just the beginning.
I'm coming for everything.
- The results are in, the winner is
(intense music)
Dio.
- Nani?
- Masaka!
- Dio has won by default,
as Jojoma did not submit his code.
(intense music)
- Wait, that's impossible, I sent it.
(Dio laughs)
- You did.
And I received it.
(intense music)
- What are you talking about?
- I spoofed the judge's email,
and you fell for it.
(intense music continues)
You sent your code to me,
and I took your code and
submitted it for myself.
(intense music continues)
(keys clack)
- Wait, that's cheating.
You cheated! How's this even allowed?
- You might have found the vulnerability
in the smart contract,
but I found a vulnerability in you.
And you were right,
I did take everything from you,
including the code today.
(Dio laughs)
I guess it does run in
the family, brother.